oh hi welcome back to game life III has
now come and gone and we were there on
the show floor to soak it all in and now
that I've burned my clothes and taken
several extensive showers we are ready
to present to you game life's official
e3 Awards the award for best head shot
goes to Sony's the last of us on
PlayStation 3 this year's e3 was all
about guns guns guns & bows and stabbing
people in the neck but mostly guns
shooting millions of policies killing
thousands of people has become
absolutely meaningless in video games as
opposed to real life we're firing one
single bullet can have life-changing
consequences and that's why Naughty
Dog's game the last of us was so
impressive especially its heart pounding
final sequence showing the one single
bullet that can have a massive emotional
impact this year's award for biggest
flirt goes to next generation video game
consoles xbox 360 came out in 2005
making it positively ancient by video
game standards but did Microsoft show a
new machine no and neither did Sony but
that's not stopping video game
publishers who aren't going to sit
around and wait for the future for
different publishers showed off next
generation tech aimed at nebulous
upcoming platforms epic showed Unreal
Engine 4 lucasarts showed Star Wars 1313
Ubisoft Hetta game called watchdogs and
Square Enix showed off the next
generation of Final Fantasy the message
was clear if hardware makers don't show
off new machines publishers will do it
for them next the you so crazy award
goes to Nintendo's Wii U nintendo's new
console with its tablet based controller
was the talk of the show although a lot
of that talk was about how Nintendo
might finally it's gone off the deep end
all of the wii u's games are built
around what the company calls asymmetric
gameplay multiplayer gameplay where
everybody does something totally
different Wii U is unique but III
attendees were kind of confused as to
whether or not they actually need one
then again
Xbox showed off smart glass which lets
you use a tablet with your 360 and Sony
let's use the Vita's touchscreen with
the PlayStation 3 so Nintendo's rivals
seem to think it might be onto something
also people thought the nintendo DS was
crazy and look how that turned out now
before we get to the big winner of e3
let's take a look at e3's biggest loser
the PlayStation Vita with incredibly
sluggish hardware sales and minimal
software Sony needed some big Megaton
announcements to assure people that the
PlayStation Vita actually has a future
what we got was a tiny handful of games
and the biggest one assassin's creed
liberation looks really good but it's
being sent to die it's launching on the
same day as assassins creed 3 which
Assassin's Creed game are you going to
buy exactly call of duty's coming out
for Vita this year but as of now it's
just a logo otherwise no big Vita games
and no price drop make it seem like sony
has just given up and finally the big
winner of e3 coming out of nowhere is
Ellen Page you heard me right the Juno
actress made the biggest splash of e3
since she is starring in beyond 2 souls
the next game from heavy rain creator
David cage Sony showed off amazing new
cinematic scenes and gameplay for this
PlayStation 3 supernatural thriller
Ellen Page did extensive voice and
motion capture work you play both as
Ellen page's character Jodie Holmes and
iden a mysterious spirit who is tied to
her character somehow either way we
cannot wait to explore all of this games
mysteries and that is why beyond is the
best game from e3
you